how you doing man also went place did
you realize you ran the red light
underneath the interstate no onestly
okay yeah there's a red light and there
was the second red light you don't
remember the first one okay no I didn't
see it you got your last registration
Insurance
[Applause]
Andy
is this vehicle yours or somebody else's
no it's mine
okay my
[Music]
license where we all coming from tonight
we just want
from
okay where's that I'm not familiar it's
2 hours south okay you're heading to C
Co now then no no no I'm going the house
oh okay where's that at uh okay
okay looking for reg okay I honestly
have never been pulled over so I don't
know reg uh looks like a little half
sheet of paper that has your vehicle
right there
yep thank you
man do you have your insurance Hand by
chance I swear this is my first time I'm
sorry just had it if not I can probably
find
it like I'm I just good okay I'm
sorry no he
said yeah I have the insurance insur so
you're leaving a friend's house you're
going to drop her off in St Pete you
just didn't see the light no yeah sorry
all right give me a second I'll get you
out here just tight I'm sorry thank
you
going give you registration Insurance
back so you're coming from a friend's
house going to drop her off and anything
else going on tonight okay okay is
anyone in the car been drinking no no
you the ones been drinking tonight okay
just cuz of the way you're driving and
and what's going on want to make sure
it's okay for you driving T you're not
haven't consumed any alcohol at all no I
SAR a Bible are you on any kind of
medication affects your bu drive any
Vision issues that affect your bu Drive
none at all okay you mind St out the
vehicle for me
[Applause]
yeah we'll still back behind that car if
you don't mind just the
roadway so man' just based on what's
going on I'm walk you through a DUI
investigation to make sure you're not to
in PR to be driving okay do you have any
physical issues okay no is it okay take
a look try
make you can't just be fa put your feet
together Put Your Arms by aside from me
okay are you comfortable standing and
walking in those shoes okay of course do
you see the top of this P right here
okay I do okay what I'm going to do is
I'm going to move it back and forth
you're going to fall with your eyes and
your eyes only while you keep your head
still okay okay just going keep your
head still and fall with your eyes
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry you can bling
like normal just going to slow down a
little bit just keep calling with your
eyesi one more
time walking through two markes to make
sure it's okay if you be driving walk on
line and standing on one foot you have
any physical issues doing that okay can
you a favor can you stand right there
stand right there for me just give me
one second it with you
okay all right man' do you see this
white line in the pavement okay course
what I'm going to have you do is put
your U leave your left foot just where
it is go ahead and put your right foot
directly in front of your left with the
heel your right foot touching the toe of
your left yeah you're to keep your arms
directly by your side and you're going
to stand just like that until you tell
otherwise okay okay when I tell you to
you're going to take nine heel toe steps
on the line in the following manner can
of each step out loud okay okay it's
going to look like this 1 2 three all
the way till 9 okay once you hit that
nin step you're going to take us through
the small steps turn around n9h steps
back down the line one 2 3 all the way
till 9 okay it's important once you
start don't stop and Keep Your Arms by
air side okay do you have any questions
for me I don't have any questions I'll
tell you when I get to nine though right
if you want to count out that's I count
out L for you that's important though
once you start don't stop okay of course
um go ahead and put your right foot
directly in front of your left here we
go if you don't have any questions
whenever you're ready may I don't have
any questions one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 can
I turn around yep just like I showed
you
1 3 four five 6
seven8 you can't you can stand right
here for me thank you going to put your
feet together Put Your Arms by your side
okay for this one you have a choices
your left to your right foot okay I'm
going to demonstrate my right foot
that's cuz that's what I prefer but if
you want to use your left it's your
choice okay don't do anything yet let me
show you first and we'll go from there
okay okay so when I tell you to you're
going to lift either your left or your
right foot about switch it off the
ground keeping that foot par with the
ground we're looking the to that for you
to count out loud 1 1000 21 000 3 1,000
and tell you tell you to stop okay it's
going like this don't do anything let me
show you first okay your feet are going
to be together arms are going to be by
your side in the air parallel with the
ground you're going to look at the toe
of the foot and you're just going to
count out loud 1 1,000 2 1,00 3 1,00 and
tell crazy you're just going to do
exactly what I'm doing right now okay I
feel you if for any reason you put your
foot down you're just going to pick it
up and keep counting until I tell you to
stop okay it's important why you do this
you keep your arms by your side and you
look at the toe of the foot while you're
counting out loud okay okay which foot
do you want to lift I feel like probably
right honestly it it's whatever your
it's your choice that's whatever you
want to do okay honestly I feel like
it's a Los is probably right okay so if
you don't have any questions whenever
you're ready you may begin okay
okay ready okay whenever you're ready
two how I three until I tell you to stop
6 remember you're look at the toe of the
foot while you count out
loud
was
11 tell me how long you're going to keep
counting until I tell you to
stop 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 remember
you're going look at the tail of the
foot you count out loud 15 16 17 18 19
20 ma you going to put your foot down
two okay for this next part go ahead and
put your feet together Put Your Arms by
your side do not mov until I tell you
to well man' based on my observations
tonight I do believe you are too
impaired to be
driving so you're are being placed in
ARR for D tonight why tell me what I did
uh well you first started over run
running the red light that'd be the
first part I didn't run a red light
unfortunately you remember you did we're
going to step back to my
vehicle can I talk to my phone real
quick we'll get her out of the car and
you can talk to her in your phone second
in the meantime we got St back to my
vehicle I literally
pass
641 you have a fem Avil for
search can you do me a
favor I'm listen to you we'll get she'll
be to talk to here in a second
sh have a seen the vehicle for me ma'
how hard
are no like literally you'll be able to
talk to him just grab
seat that shit is fucking loud
I fucking test
bro pass every
test this shit is crazy I'm fucking
sober what' you say oh the
sure she wanted to talk to
you thanks for calling me
back if you want to grab any property
that out the
vehicle all that stuff is yours none of
it
first I mean it's a first no no I said
grab any belongs to you out of the
vehicle okay that's sure is you can put
her stuff back inside the car
then she wanted to talk to
you it's
legit go into my phone right now do you
have my phone it's in the car no you
have to go get it right now go get my
phone and come back right now no like
legit get my phone to come
out well you're not going to be able to
take anything out right now bam she just
I just need her to call my friend out
right now it's
okay can wait
Kira I legit he legit I passed every
single fucking test it's fucking psycho
he was like I still don't believe you're
fucking can drive I pass every single
fucking test bro I need you to get my
fucking get my phone and call
BJ the like uh is your phone still in
the car yes can she get my phone
please okay it this shit is fucking
crazy because I passed every single
fucking tatto he's just being an asshole
bro it's not fucking faite I swear I
swear and he's like I still don't
believe you like legit on his fucking
body cam he look like I swear to you it
would be like she passed every fucking
page bro get my DJ like if you get my
phone
fucking BJ like go get my phone right
now BJ
BJ I don't have the last name you just
get
fucking going to
be5
down uh 71
Bravo she said her
phone no I have lotion oh I do I that's
your that was
my 6 71 I'm did you just take my phone
no I
have right now like literally
T face on yep yep call Face Time please
please the
sheriff1 tell him that I passed every
single sorry I
I'm if he doesn't answer just keep
calling I'm so upset because I passed
every test it's so rude bro you saw me
pass every test only test I saw was the
one we cup
and I pass passed that one I passed
every T like bro I need the body Canam
footage immediately because that
shit I can't fucking wait I can't wait I
can't
[Music]
wait honestly I have had one
what he
tell
him um bra got pulled over and she
passed every single and I'm in the back
seat of a fucking cop car c car give him
the
cup I swear I pass give it to
him give it to
him what do you
say
EJ
can you bro I passed every single test
and they are just being not
nice I don't know can you turn the
camera around and tell them please
bro this shit is crazy Kira turn the
camera around
please
DJ
please I legit am in the back of the
fucking cop car could they I passed
every test and he was being mean and he
was like you didn't pass even though I
fucking did everyone watch me pass even
this guy it was like you did pass and
this other guy is just like not
nice you
I legit am in in hand hubs
please
please where you at I am on the where am
I at on the side of the fucking highway
by I'm on that side of 275
and near eore is
yeah I
you're can you please help
me phone to the opp please okay give it
to him
s so hey what's up man
um what do we got I I'm up here backing
up a DUI unit ask me to come up on scene
he' already done all the
sfsts got here
was I've pass literally everything they
about to take her down
to okay um going look they're going to
let the other girl take a
car is her friend
sherff wait St
what is she say
ke you step away from
the take I already called it in you
stand by with it yeah see you got you
got one already com yeah man you can go
and step on the
sidewalk can I help youall
huh waiting on there waiting on who
those are okay what are you picking
someone up or yeah we're trying to see
if is there more than one person in the
car okay I guess they're the ride oh man
that's your ride is this your ride
here not did you call for a
ride yes is it a friend or is like a
Uber or lip and they're here to give do
you know them yeah okay you're free to
go all right man' you can step out this
office we going to search and make sure
you have nothing illegal on your person
okay hi hi you have anything sharp on
you that's going to poke stick or stab
anything that could be considered
contraband drugs weapons anything like
that though literally nothing all right
just face the car for me there you
go
is it sewn in or glued in or SE
okay you just relax your arm you can
relax your arm
you huh trying to help no you're fine
you're
fine
do you have something melt in your
pocket no I do probably
okay all right spread your feet a little
bit for
me yeah I'm going to put this in your
your
property okay thank
you all right open your mouth for me
tongue
up okay all right going to have a
seat
yeah thank you you're
welcome
um
my did they can I get them to call like
my phone call your phone like they were
using my phone to call my friend
oh that's not I have her phone you have
her phone yeah he's got your phone no
not him no he listen he got your phone
from your friend so he he's got your
phone
now unless you have more than one do you
have more than one phone no I was just
trying to get he got it from her my
friend he got
it oh I didn't do fucking shit
to go
okay that's really not
fair
674 674 I can't fucking say
I
at um quite a few places what were the
few places though it'll be documenting
the report
running okay
period cuz I would love to fucking see
that okay it's on video as well I know I
know it is that's why I want to see it
okay
cuz I had one fucking drink so this shit
is literally insane to
me it literally is
insane it's not fucking
fair I understand that like you don't
like probably pretty people because they
don't like you but like the fact that
you Target
them I did not mess up one part of that
fucking
test so I would love to see the fucking
playback because I know you're going to
do shit
wrong because I'm fucking sober this
shit is fucking
[Music]
crazy
[Applause]
step out thank
you I button this no I'm not going to
touch your clothing we s of these green
doors right here